hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called
surrogates spoilers ahead watch out and
stay safe in early scenes we discover
that humans have built robots that will
replace people in daily life surrogates
as they are known are controlled by STEM
chairs using neuropathic signals humans
remain safe in their own houses while
their surrogates live their lives for
them as bigotry and hatred fade crime
rates fall in societal living conditions
improve however dreads are
anti-surrogacy activists start to launch
campaigns against the robots they accuse
the surrogates of being liars and
deceivers the dreads have collected and
isolated isolation zones around the
planet led by Zaire Powell the scene
moves to a wealthy young man who is
transported to a nightclub he starts
dancing with a woman and then they go to
the back alley to kiss in the process a
figure emerges and interrupts them the
man tells the figure to leave but the
couple is abruptly struck by lightning
the FBI's agents Peters and Greer arrive
on the scene and discover the man and
lady to be surrogates they discover ever
that the male surrogate is unregistered
whereas the female surrogate has been
allocated to someone but the owner
hasn't filed any reports they noticed
the surrogate's eyes are burned out and
Greer notices the male surrogate's
memory chip is fried Greer and Peters
then go to the female surrogate's
apartment where they discover him dead
with his nose bloodied Greer examines
the last thing the surrogate saw and
notices the male surrogate's eyes burn
and shatter before the feet is cut off
Greer then returns home and pours
himself a glass of water demonstrating
that he is also a surrogate the
surrogate then enters a closet and parks
Greer then rises from his chair and goes
to see his wife Maggie Brier suggests a
vacation however Maggie suggests taking
their surrogates to Hawaii but Greer
prefers to leave the surrogates at home
and have them go out physically in a
college dormitory some teens discover
their friend Jared on his chair lifeless
and covered in blood Andrew the police
chief then informs the station of the
discovery they found that the two
operators Jared and the female surrogate
operator had their brain is liquefied
whatever happened to their surrogate
seems to have killed them Greer and
Peters examine the surrogate tape and
notice a man with a firearm Greer
informs Andrew that the case appears to
be a homicide they are subsequently
informed via phone that Jared is the son
of surrogacy pioneer Lionel Cantor the
father of surrogacy regrettably he was
removed from his company several years
ago by his Partners Greer and Peters
then pay a visit to Lionel they're LED
in and met by one of Lionel surrogates
Lionel then tells the cops the story of
the Dead teen Jared as Jared started
college his father Lionel offered him
the use of any of his surrogates Peters
then emphasizes the significance of not
enabling other users to borrow
surrogates registered to other people
Greer inquires if Lionel is aware of
anyone who would like to harm himself or
Jared Lionel realizes that the
assassination was intended for him
rather than Jared the Assassin was
unaware that the person acting as Lionel
surrogate was Jared Lionel logs out of
the surrogate after realizing this Greer
and Peters then traveled to the company
which creates surrogates to meet with
Representatives Greer inquires as to
whether they are aware of any incidents
involving a surrogate's head bursting
and the surrogate operator dying the
representatives grow defensive assuring
Greer that there are safeguards in place
to protect against such mishaps they
then make their way to the engineering
floor to speak with one of the engineers
Greer shows him the fried identity chip
from Jarred surrogate and the engineer
says the only way this could happen is
if all of the circuits fired at the same
time the engineer also informs them that
a truckload of surrogates arrived from
the military missing Optics and identity
chips Greer and Peters then travel to a
military base to observe surrogate
troops fighting a war on the battlefield
the surrogate is shot and killed and the
operator immediately jumps back in with
a different surrogate the military
Colonel tells them that any weapon used
on a surrogate will have no impact on
the surrogate's operator he also notes
that the military routinely removes
surrogate motherboards and optics for
investigation back at the police station
Peters recognizes the man in the
surveillance footage holding the firearm
as non-surgate user miles they then
proceed to the monitoring department
where Bobby and non-surgate technician
informs them that Miles has been located
career heads up to meet with the pursuit
Squad while Peter's remains with Bobby
to track miles location Bobby then tells
Peters that identifying miles was simple
because they have access to all of the
city's surrogate feeds and alarm sounds
and Bobby Witnesses a man assaulting a
woman he calls it in and requests that
the assailant surrogate be shut down
immediately bobby gets served with the
disconnection warrant and quickly shuts
down the surrogates Peters is taken
aback because she had no idea surrogates
could be turned off remotely now Peters
is concerned about the program falling
into the hands of the wrong people miles
rides his motorcycle through the streets
his police cars follow him he swerves
through the traffic narrowly avoiding
oncoming Vehicles Brier pursues the
suspects in a helicopter miles is then
forced to stop in an alley and is
cornered police swarm him and Miles
pulls out a weapon causing the pursuing
officers to be blasted with an electric
shock all of the police surrogates
convulse and their eyes bulge out he
then directs the device toward the
helicopter prayer collapses and
disconnects from the surrogate as
swiftly as possible Niles comes over a
dread town and the chopper begins to
drift towards it as well Greer returns
to his surrogate only to find himself in
the dread isolation Zone Greer emerges
from the debris and begins pursuing
miles as the dread residents notice that
a surrogate has entered the Zone they
become enraged and begin pursuing Greer
Greer and Miles Sprint through the slums
passing several trailers Greer easily
leaps over trailers and climbs them
until he catches up to Miles Greer
demands that Miles hand up the weapons
and Miles obliges by handing Greer a bag
Greer was blown away by a shotgun blast
before he could unzip the bag miles
takes the firearm back and Greer is shot
by a lady who calls him an Abomination
Breer walks away from his surrogate and
out of his stimming chair he crawls over
the floor screaming out to Maggie she
soon locates Greer and calls an
ambulance miles later awakens to find
the prophet Powell and his men
ransacking his home in search of the
weapon Powell inquires about the origin
of the weapon and Miles admits that he
never found out who it belonged to
according to a news story Powell
interpreted the wrecked helicopter as an
attack on the dreads house and started a
revolution against surrogate users
meanwhile Greer awakens in the hospital
and Adam informs him that he has been
suspended Adam says he'll handle the
case himself and tells Greer to relax
Greer flees the hospital and raged at
the bureau's decision he is concerned
that the bureau will not share his fear
about miles weapon Peters immediately
meets him and they begin their Journey
back to the station Greer becomes dizzy
and disoriented as he walks according to
Peters it's a side effect of being in
the surrogate for too long prayer
chooses to go visit the dread Colony
assuming he'll be able to get in easily
now that he's not using a surrogate
within he sees his surrogate crucified
and learns that miles is no longer alive
Powell talks during miles funeral
reminding the attendees that Miles death
unlike the surrogates is a symbol of
true Humanity Greer approaches Powell
after the burial but when he refuses to
leave Powell's thugs beat him up later
Greer inquires about the weapon but
Powell laughs and responds sarcastically
Greer departs and Powell enters his
trailer to grab the weapon lying beneath
the floor Greer gets into a car that has
pulled up behind him a young boy reveals
that he is another of Lionel surrogate
after the assassination attempt Lionel
claims he can't utilize his normal
surrogates Greer informs Lionel that
Jared's assassin has been murdered by
Powell Lionel then tells him to focus on
finding the weapon they'll know who
wanted Lionel dead if they figure out
where the weapon came from According to
Lionel the dreads are incapable of
creating such a weapon because it would
necessitate extensive research and
funding Greer then returns home and has
an altercation with Maggie he wants to
see his real wife not a surrogate Maggie
then enters her room and looks in the
mirror she removes her goggles and sobs
on her stimming chair Greer returns to
the station and discovers that the
company creating the surrogates has
signed a weapon deal with the military
later that night a surrogate it enters
Peter's house it examines recordings of
what Peters has seen and discovers
information on Bobby and the police's
capacity to tap into all surrogates the
surrogate then repeatedly shoots a
sleeping Peters it then implants a
remote operator into Peter's surrogate
Peter's surrogate comes to life at the
station the next day Greer meets with
the military Colonel and shows him a
picture of the weapon the colonel admits
to knowing about the weapon's existence
and reveals that it's an overload device
designed for the military however all
prototypes were thought to have been
destroyed after the testing phase Greer
then informs the colonel that the dreads
have obtained the weapon the colonel
immediately rushes out and informs Greer
that the military will be in charge of
retrieving the weapon Powell passes the
weapon to his henchmen in the terror
Zone and orders them to deliver it to
Peters at the police station meanwhile
Greer visits Maggie's salon and wants to
talk about what is happening between
them Aggie reminds Greer that the only
reason she is still living today is
because of her surrogate who gave her an
escape from her life at home Maggie
grabs a bottle of pills from a stack and
takes one meanwhile the military has
begun an assault on the dread Zone in
order to recover the weapon troops pour
out of helicopters as the terrified
residents flee to safety Howell and his
henchmen attempt to flee but are
apprehended by soldiers a gunfight
breaks out between Powell's men and the
military but Powell's men are quickly
overpowered Cowell is shot and when the
military approaches they notice that
Powell the anti-surrogacy movement's
leader is himself a surrogate Lionel is
finally identified as Powell's operator
Greer meets with the surrogate whom he
believes is Peter and learns that Miles
has been working with Andrew miles had
been paid by Andrew to assassinate
Lionel Greer then enters the station to
confront Andrew about what he has
discovered as Andrew looks away Greer
stabs the surrogate in the back of the
skull knocking it out he then gains
access to Andrew's computer and
downloads anything related to the
company creating surrogates and Miles he
then meets Peter's surrogate and drives
away prayer deduces from the files that
Lionel is funding the anti-surrogacy
movement Greer then discovers the codes
required to activate the weapon Peters
then calls the station to inform them of
Greer's location a truck hits them at
that moment and the automobile is tossed
Greer decides to pursue Peters and try
to run her over as she walks away with
the weapon they end up driving through
congested streets running over
surrogates and colliding with other cars
Greer crashes into a store window but
Peter escapes Greer flees the pursuing
FBI agents and steals a car he phones
Bobby and orders him to shut down
Peter's surrogate but Peters is already
there and Bobby informs Greer that she
is attempting to access the entire
surrogate Network Andrew walks up to the
monitoring level and confronts Peters he
attempts to communicate with Peters but
Lionel shows that he is in control of
Peter's surrogate Andrews tells Lionel
that they were forced to kill him
because he tried to stop the surrogates
Lionel goes on to claim that he merely
wants people to live like humans he then
shoots the weapon at Andrew shorting out
and destroying his surrogate's computer
Greer arrives at Lionel's house and
insists on speaking with the real Lionel
he then forces his way in looking for
Lionel meanwhile Peter's surrogate
launches a virus upload into all
surrogates with the intention of killing
everyone who uses a surrogate Greer
discovers a secret door and penetrates
it to reach Lionel's chamber he finds
many surrogates in the room including
Powell and the man who murdered Peters
Greer then discovers Lionel in a
wheelchair aiming a gun at him Lionel
believes that surrogacy has become a
distortion of mankind and a horrible
Obsession a warning tone signals that
the virus upload has been completed now
that he has reached his goal Lionel
takes his own life by swallowing a
cyanide pill Grier then removes Lionel
from the stemming chair and enters
Peter's surrogate he asks Bobby how they
can stop the virus from spreading and
Bobby walks him through the process
Greer successfully pauses the
transmission with less than a second
remaining although the operators are
safe the virus is still active and would
kill surrogates while a team of
operatives enters the facility Bobby
educates Greer on how to protect the
surrogates from being destroyed Greer
pauses as he is about to find finalize
the virus termination and instead
decides to allow the virus to be
transferred to surrogates an operator
shoots Peter surrogate as Greer presses
the button as the virus becomes active
all of the surrogates become lifeless
prayer emerges to discover that the
virus has successfully incapacitated all
surrogates and people begin to emerge
from their homes confused Greer returns
home and discovers his wife standing at
the window Maggie kisses Grier on the
cheek and the two Embrace Humanity has
returned to the world uncertain of what
lies ahead thanks for watching subscribe
and hit that like button to help our
Channel grow turn on the notifications
so you won't miss any of our new videos